[Applaudissements]
bariteau de la la
way you love
est-ce qu'il y en a qui connaissent ce
titre de tiken jah fakoly qui vient de
passer lever la mer s'il vous plaît je
vois parfait il ya des amateurs de
reggae je pense qu'on va passer de bons
moments
parce qu'on va parler de reggae dans ce
titre de tiken jah fakoly il explique à
quel point aujourd'hui plus que jamais
l'afrique a besoin de ses fils exilé les
africains de la diaspora dans ce même
titre
tiken jah fakoly sont dans deux langues
en anglais et en bambara en anglais un
peu comme pour l'heure
confortés dans leur décision d'être
parti de s'ouvrir au monde et dieu sait
que ces gens là sont partis pour
plusieurs raisons trop souvent pour des
raisons politiques trop souvent pour des
raisons économiques
parfois pour des raisons sociales et
parfois même pour des raisons
culturelles
ils sont en bambara est un dialecte
local ou à ces africains qu'on parle
dans plusieurs pays comme le sénégal le
mali la côte d'ivoire la guinée la
gambie la mauritanie et ses portes pour
leur dire aussi de se rappeler de là
d'où ils viennent d'ailleurs qu'il le
dit avec un adage africain
quel que soit le séjour du tronc d'arbre
dans l'eau 22 transformera jamais un
crocodile
d'hygiène jah fakoly pour ceux qui ne le
connaissent pas est un artiste très
engagé pour le développement de
l'afrique
quelqu'un que j'apprécie beaucoup même
si j'ai pas tout le temps était d'accord
pour toutes les positions
mais quelqu'un avec qui je partage une
vision celle d'une afrique nouvelle et
émergentes
porté par ses fils d'ici et d'ailleurs
quand on m'a demandé de faire cette
intervention sur la diaspora
j'ai eu un peu de mal à formaliser mon
titre en fait à le ponctué quand on
parle du rôle de la diaspora africaine
aujourd'hui c'est une évidence pour tous
les africains ils diront oui évidemment
c'est des gens qui sont la peau pour
faire avancer le continent
ils sont même il le crie haut et fort en
même temps quand vous créez un peu plus
pour essayer d'avoir des informations
plus précises
comment est-ce qu'ils vont le faire quel
est le rôle exact
d'ailleurs qui sont ces gens de la
diaspora d'où ils viennent comment ils
vivent là les réponses deviennent moins
évidente
d'où mon point d'interrogation je vais
vous parler d'un petit pays de l'afrique
de l'ouest 100 95 196 me kilomètre carré
à peine trois fois plus grand que narre
région auvergne rhône-alpes 15 millions
d'habitants
le sénégal figurent google dans ce petit
pays de l'afrique de l'ouest
rien que les sénégalais de la diaspora
en voix près des 2 milliards de dollars
par an à leurs proches est l'équivalent
du quart du budget de l'état en fait
c'est plus que l'aide internationale
oui banque mondiale effet mis tout ce
que vous entendez là ils font pas le
poids par rapport aux fonds qui sont
envoyées par les sénégalais de la
diaspora pour dire à quel point ces
gens-là pèse dans l'économie locale
tu parles de l'économie mais on peut
étendre ça aussi à de la politique
ce pays tout petit pays a connu deux
révolutions démocratiques mais tout
orchestré à partir de la diaspora ou en
tout cas beaucoup porté par des leaders
politiques de la diaspora est en fait
c'est pas nouveau
vous remontez l'histoire le premier
mouvement afro indépendantistes contre
la colonisation était porté par des
africains de la diaspora la négritude
avec des écrivains célèbres comme aimé
césaire léopold sédar senghor est devenu
par la suite qui a été admis par
l'académie française
ces gens là par la littérature ont
combattu la colonisation et ont
participé à la libération de leurs
peuples
cependant la politique mais on peut
aussi est en hausse à dans le domaine
scientifique
quelqu'un comme le professeur cheikh
anta diop scientifiques reconnues au
niveau international avait beaucoup
d'ouvragés à son à son titre comme
nationale gré culture l'antériorité de
la cie des civilisations aux
normes qui par la science a montré
l'empreinte de l'homme noir dans l'une
des premières civilisations les plus
évolués l'egypte ancienne et dans tant
d'autres domaines où on voit l'empreinte
de cette diaspora africaine
dans le domaine politique économique
social culturel scientifique et pourtant
quand vous demandez aux états africains
alors vous demandez aux africains en
général et les la connaissance précise
qu'ils ont de ces gens là devient un peu
plus compliqué parce qu'on a une
mauvaise connaissance de ces personnes
cela a même créé une certaine
frustration c'est certain en tout cas
une frustration que moi j'ai connu en
tant qu'africaine la diaspora c'est bon
ça je vais vous raconter mon histoire
d'africains de la diaspora frustré je
suis né au sénégal où j'ai passé une
grande partie de mon enfance j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir des parents
extraordinaires qui ont fait en sorte
que l'école soit une des choses les plus
importantes de ma vie à un point tel que
pendant mon adolescence j'ai une crise
d'adolescence comme tout le monde j'ai
voulu devenir un footballeur
professionnel n'était pas mauvais en
plus vous avez réussi des tests et tout
mais j'ai encore la réplique de ma mère
qui résonne dans ma tête
elle me disait à l'époque
malik tu n'entendras jamais quelqu'un
dire je vais travailler au football on
dit je vais jouer au football
un raccourci pour ma mère pour essayer
de me faire comprendre que en fait le
foot c'était pas un métier
c'était aux loisirs aux oeufs c'est
discutable aujourd'hui on est d'accord
mais cela m'a beaucoup aidé et je la
remercierai jamais assez pour ça ça m'a
permis aujourd'hui de faire des grandes
écoles aujourd'hui je suis ingénieur
télécoms diplômé de l'insee pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas c'est un des plus
grands réseaux d'écoles d'ingénieurs en
france qui forment le croire entre 20 et
25% des ingénieurs français et j'ai eu
la chance aussi d'avoir un diplôme de
management de l'essai de grenoble
tous ses diplômes là m'ont permis de
faire mes premières armes dans des
entreprises importantes comme une
filiale du groupe highco cotées au cac
40 ou alors chez eads la maison mère
d'airbus ou encore dans une filiale du
centre national d études spatiales et
pendant tout ce temps comme la plupart
des sénégalais de la diaspora
moi aussi j'ai envoyé de l'argent à la
famille et envoyait beaucoup d'argent
mais paradoxalement est ce que je vais
vous dire là mais très personnel ça
n'engage que moi c'est pas forcément le
cas des autres plus envoyer moins utile
je me sentais pas ce que je m'apercevais
que l'argent que j'envoyais ne résolvait
pas forcément les problématiques
économiques et sociales auxquelles
auraient voulu m'attaquer
et ça a créé une nouvelle frustration là
l'école a été très important pour moi
notamment mes cours d'économie et je
remercie encore mes professeurs pour ça
on le dit pas assez souvent mais mes
profs d'économie ont réussi à me faire
comprendre à quel point l'entreprise et
les entrepreneurs était important dans
le développement d'une société apparaît
tout évident mais les entreprises
mettent de la richesse dans les caisses
de l'état pour le bien commun
les entreprises créent la richesse brut
pour la société et mieux encore
ce sont les vecteurs de l'emploi chez
moi au dit que une personne qui
travaille nourrit dix autres personnes
autour d'elle autrement dit si vous
faites travailler 10 personnes vous
participez à l'épanouissement social 200
autres personnes
à partir de là c'était devenu une
évidence pour moi en fait que si on
devait impacté autrement l'un des
meilleurs moyens
ce serait peut-être l'entrepreneuriat
ces deux là d'où est née l'idée de
l'africa mobile est une start-up
sénégalaise existe depuis trois ans avec
un credo il répond à nos deux
prestations antérieures
le credo c'est de mettre à disposition
des outils numériques qui permettent de
mieux connaître la ga sport mais qui
aussi les implique davantage sur les
problématiques locales sociale
concrètement aujourd'hui nous
travaillons avec des médias
locaux africains des radios des
télévisions sur des concepts d'émissions
où l'on fait venir des politiques des
maires des ministres et on donne la
possibilité en direct aux gens de la
diaspora de pouvoir poser leurs
questions en temps réel via le mobile et
les réseaux sociaux
un autre exemple nous travaillons aussi
avec des associations qui sont impliqués
dans des problématiques locales souvent
sociale aux humanitaires comme par
exemple la lutte contre le cancer
la scolarisation d'enfants de familles
défavorisées ou encore la construction
d'orphelinats avec ces associations là
où les accompagnons sur la communication
digitale
mais surtout nous leur donnons des
moyens numériques qui permettent
simplement de collecter de l'argent
facilement via le mobile avec les gens
de la diaspora africaine
un autre exemple nous travaillons aussi
avec des organismes internationaux sur
des concours d'entrepreneuriat où l'idée
c'est aussi de permettre aux africains
de la diaspora de pouvoir donner leur
voix de pouvoir voter pour choisir de
meilleur projet en tout cas les
meilleurs projets qui sont par la suite
il bénéficie par la suite d'un
accompagnement et éventuellement d'un
financement par d'autres exemples où je
pourrai pas citer malheureusement avec
le temps qui m'est imparti
mais ces petites expériences nous a
aussi permis de voir
les opportunités qu'il ya en afrique moi
j'avais jamais eu la sens même si je
suis originaire d'afrique j'ai jamais eu
la chance de travailler en afrique avant
cette expérience là cette petite
expérience et belle expérience qui ne
fait que commencer finalement mais qui
nous a permis de voir aussi les
opportunités qu'il ya en afrique
actuellement
vous prenez rien que l'afrique de
l'ouest des gens qui majoritairement
parle français comme nous tous
d'ailleurs pour ceux qui ne le savent
pas actuellement 50% des gens qui
parlent le français dans le monde vivent
en afrique et ce chiffre là va passer à
80% d'ici quelques années une
opportunité énorme pour nous tous ici
pour ceux qui sont dans le domaine du
numérique
je dirais vous que dans 10 dans des pays
comme le sénégal le taux de pénétration
du mobile est supérieur à 100%
autrement dit vous êtes dans un
territoire où vous avez plus de
téléphones mobiles que d'être de
personnes vivantes
est ce que cela veut dire ça veut dire
simplement que pour ceux qui ont des
services à passer sur le sur le mobile
c'est pas si une opportunité énorme mais
dû à un usage parce que les gens ont
deux trois quatre
parfois même cinq téléphones en même
temps c'est incroyable j'ai parle du du
numérique qui est mon domaine mais dans
d'autres domaines comme les énergies
renouvelables le solaire
l'agrobusiness le biogaz etc etc
aujourd'hui les startups africaines ont
compris cela
figurez-vous que 5 sur l'année 2016 les
start-up africaine de dakar à naïrobi dé
casablanca au cap
on levait 360 millions de dollars sur
c'est une évolution de 30% 33% pardon
par rapport à 2015 ça paraît beaucoup
mais à mes yeux pas suffisant
avec tout ce que j'ai vu comme
innovation c'est absolument pas
suffisant ya encore beaucoup de choses à
faire là-dessus et c'est là où j'en
appelle la diaspora africaine qui me
regardent aujourd'hui en leur disant que
même s'ils n'ont pas la possibilité de
créer des entreprises
ils peuvent plus se défiler parce que
ils ont la possibilité d'investir dans
ces pépites africaine qui aujourd'hui
n'attendons que ça et je finis par là où
j'ai commencé à rejoigne en tiken jah
fakoly ce qu'il disait au début
aujourd'hui puisque jamais l'afrique a
besoin de ses fils exilé vous remercie
de votre attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]